[Music]
it's really bright here um thank you Jed
for um a perfect pronunciation of my
surname which is really hard to do for
anyone who's not from
Poland um first of all I would like to
say uh thank you to Christina and
Michael and everyone who's um putting
this event on because it's just amazing
and the quality of talks is mindblowing
and I'm really humbled that I'm closing
this conference and I don't know if I
can live up to the expectations of of of
closing such a great conference but I
will do my best to to do so so um as
Jeet said I'm I'm kolina I'm from
krackow I work for a software company
called and yet I've been doing mostly
design and development for 10 years now
uh I've studied human computer
interaction which is probably one of the
reasons why I will talk to you not about
CSS and HTML and Technology but more of
a like soft skills I
guess so the way I want to start this
conversation when I'm just going to talk
to you and you're just going to sit
there is uh what is
creativity I feel like um technology
changes new Frameworks are introduced
every sing day or week or month but
technology can be mastered relatively
easily well when you think about a human
being we don't really know that much
relatively about how our brains work we
know pretty a lot of stuff about how our
bodies work but not how our brains work
so if you think about it Nar sense is
quite a baby so what is creativity how
do I work how do I work alone how do I
work with others in a team are people
empowering me to be creative am I
empowering myself to be creative is my
work only valid if I get extend some
external validation and Appraisal of
others or should I just do it myself and
say hey great work you're just the best
person ever so do I search it within
myself or others um so let's start and
try to Define
creativity which I guess we wish that we
could just like click our fingers and
yeah I'm creative in the creative mode
right now and it just totally works like
that um probably most of you are um
familiar with the concept and this
particular image of of the brain split
into two hemispheres the left one and
the right one well where each of those
are in governance of separate processes
the left one is the smart one the
mathematical one The Logical one and the
right one is the emotional emotional one
and the creative one um unfortunately
this image is quite settled in pop
culture and it's somewhat true but on
the other hand quite false as the fact
that we use only 10% of our
brains um creativity cannot be assigned
to just one part right part of our brain
or whatever arbitrary part of our brain
it is a process that spans across all of
our
brains
so if you think about creativity and
attempts on defining it the one of the
first definitions of creativity uh was
created in 1920s by English philos
philosopher philosopher philos I'm just
trying to give up on this word Graham
wall that was his name um an English guy
and he wrote this book called The a of
thought and he thought that creative it
can be divided in stages which totally
makes sense and the first stage is
preparation so kind of figuring out what
I'm trying to create like oh I'm into
like creating an I don't know like
interactive app that lets me upload
pictures so initial interest in a
certain topic and gathering information
about
it the second uh stage is incubation
which um might might sound a little bit
weird but on the other and is quite
familiar when you think about it it's
inter internalization of a problem and
kind of stepping away so like I have
this vag idea that I want to do
something with photography and uploading
pictures but um I feel like I need to
break now and I need to step down for a
minute or I've been working for too long
so I need to go for a walk and clear my
mind and take like an inspiration break
that's what incubation is it's supposed
to stimulate new thoughts and and I get
ideas flowing the third stage is
elimination which means the AHA or like
AA moment not without jumping out of the
B thing um when the idea or solution for
a problem that we are searching for is
discovered and is acknowledge okay I
totally know how I'm going to solve this
now and the fourth stage the last one is
verification so actual practical
execution of this idea that that we had
so when we think about this definition
it looks okay like makes sense but feels
somewhat ambiguous and dated I mean it
was quite a while like um fortunately
creativity was something that was quite
interesting for many researchers and
more scientists so um a little bit later
on in history um James Mel roads um coin
the 4p definition of
creativity which is also uh divided in
stages the first first stage is person
which means me my traits my behavior my
value systems I basically everything
that makes me the person I
am the second stage is process invention
Lear learning thinking remembering
perception so all the processes that are
involved in creation and basically ideas
being
born and press which is my relationship
with environment so basically all of you
right now environment Society your
audience when you are creating
something and product which is tangible
result of your creative
activity whatever you ended up making so
for me that definition sounds a little
bit more right for I feel like what
creativity is and the reason why I'm
talking about defining creativity is
because I want to talk about the person
and press aspect of this definition
which means me as a person the Creator
and you as an audience of of my creative
activity you as an audience you as a
Critic of my
work so um the title of the talk is
validate me so um when you think about
creating
anything writing an app writing CSS
doing web design print design creating
fonts
whatever you might be creating making
gmit cheese or local beer um we seek
validation and we seek this for this
validation internally and in others and
our environment as we saw in those
definitions affects the creative
presses when we think about how we
interact with with others in terms of
creative ity and validation as well um I
think it's worth to go back to school
and remember how how we we were feeling
in um in the day when we when we were at
school and in my opinion when when we
you are at school the educational
institutions are building obedience
models and kind of false gist in a way
because they're promoting race for
achievements when you think about it you
get an A oh you're so great you're doing
awesome you're such a great person good
kid here's a lollipop for you but if
you're getting D then you're like a no
something's going wrong why are you did
you prepare and if you get an F you're
just like utter failure and failure is
not acceptable in in education and it
doesn't matter why you failed it just
maybe you were sick or you're not
feeling well or whatever reason but it
just doesn't matter failure is
unacceptable and your efforts whatever
they where are going to be belittle no
matter for for the reason of your
failure so when we think about it that
kind of means that approval is confused
with love and
worthiness okay good background for a
really serious talk um we are raised to
please and conform we are raised to
please and conform at school we are
raised to pleas and conform in our
families if you behave well you're going
to get those Legos finally and I'm not
saying it's a bad thing I'm not going to
try to like say something about
parenting because I'm not a parent but I
feel like those um Tendencies can build
up and can make us be really confused
about
approval that also might mean that our
internal selfworth and the feeling of
selfworth is dependent on achieving if
I'm not achieving I'm not worth anything
if I'm getting only e FS at exams or
whatever I'm just a terrible person and
I might just give up on creating
anything so at the lowest levels of
behavior we are engaging in a phenomena
called impression management which means
that we are always thinking how we
appear to others even if there's no one
around we are always trying to be
someone else and create an image of
ourselves that's going to be seen about
outside world that doesn't necessarily
align with who we really are and that's
quite uncomfortable place to be
at we are what we pretend to be so we
must be careful about what we pretend to
be we all are part of certain groups
group of developers designers front-end
developers backend
developers programmers however you call
it cheese
makers and the fear of banish M from a
social group or Circle sometimes may be
even greater than I feel like it was
centuries ago when we're ring around
half naked hunting bores and when
ostracism from a group mean meant
certain death like people actually get
really depressed and uh get into really
dark places when they're socially
banished and that's a very dangerous
thing about validation and that's a
really important thing to remember that
validation can be withdrawn or withheld
at any point if you're not the person
who is giving it to yourself because
someone else just gave it to you someone
said you did a really good job and if
you rely only on on that on that
external validation that might get you
quite miserable in the p in the future
if if everyone will be like ah you know
what I changed my mind you're not really
that cool so the only validation and
credit you you are in control of is the
one that you give
yourself nobody really pushes creative
people as much as they push
themselves and I feel like that's one of
the reasons why um some of us maybe
majority of this room
even experience or or will experience
impostor
phenomenon imposter phenomenon is uh is
this is syndrome that that was coined in
80s by Dr Palin Clans and it's describ
as feelings of very severe inadequacy
conviction that our achievements are
undeserved and that we will be exposed
as frauds we basically cannot inter
internalize success and we are feeling a
great disiness between the person I am
and the person I'm supposed to be the
person the society wants me to be
and a lot of people are saying that
impostor phenomenon is something that's
experienced only by smart people and
that is not necessarily true um I
actually read a lot of research papers
on imposter phenomenon to do my due
diligence for for this dog and um
imposter phenomenon is something that at
least 70% of population will experience
at least once in their lifetimes which
basically means that I could probably
say that 70% of this room had it or will
have it soon
um imposter phenomenon can be caused or
also might cause um perfectionism it
might cause or might be caused by
overworking love low self-esteem or
overprotective family
environments um initial imposter studies
also showed that there is correlation
between being an impostor and gender it
was more pointing to towards women being
more susceptible although I think it's
because it was only the studies made on
successful
women did you make this this is
excellent thank you I just don't think
it's that good what do you mean it's
great you must have the Creator's curse
when you're done making something you
improved while working on it you're
never fully satisfied with with your own
work so you make more then it goes on
like this forever and ever isn't that
neat that's basically kind of a version
of of a definition of imposter Syndrome
imposters have really really
unreasonably low ass assessments of
their performers of their performance of
themselves and this feeling is even
emphasized when they are around other
exceptional people so like let's say
this conference like will totally
emphasize my
impost recognition that we will get will
re reinforce the The Imposter syndrome
and low feelings uh instead of bringing
us
peace so when we think about impostor
syndrome and and how it works it kind of
seems a little bit vag but there is a
process called impostor cycle that
actually describes how it works pretty
well so it starts with a task an
achievement related task and let's make
it easy this is me writing this
talk so at first I'm like that this is
really cool I'm really excited about
writing this dog it's great I'm this is
going to be amazing but then slowly
those feelings start to fade and I'm
feeling a little bit worried and anxious
and doubting myself I'm I going to
perform I don't know about this maybe I
should just run or say I'm not going to
make it so when I actually get to work
um two things will happen I'll either
over prepare so read all the research
papers I will talk to psychologists
about how that works and I will do my
slides for two weeks and write the super
elaborate I don't know 20 pages long
talk or I will procrastinate to the very
very last second and then I will freak
out and was like why did they even do
it fortunately finally when I delivered
the talk there is a single moment of
relief I did it that that's I completed
the task it's it's great it's the fear
is gone the anxiety is gone the worry is
gone but
unfortunately when I think about it and
if I get positive feedback I won't I
won't take it I will reject it and the
reason why is because in the scenario of
overpreparing I will assign it to effort
okay but everyone can make an effort so
like whatever but in in the
procrastination scenario I will sign it
to luck because I did it like 2 hours
before so it's not even good it's just
it was I just laed out and people liked
it because some random reason so no
matter the fact that I had I achieved
the task I had good
feedback I still feel really anxious
even more doubting my own skills and
possibly depressed and the cycle is
closed and it begins again with with
another achievement
task so even despite whatever process I
choose for my creative activity I will
feel really guilty about this process
itself I will deny my achievements I
will deny my own
competence and I will try to avoid
failure at all
costs outperforming others and the
Imposter phenomenon um scenario will be
my goal mediocrity is not acceptable
performance infers my ability if I'm not
performant I'm not I do not have any
talents I'm not able to achieve anything
so if I'm not pulling 10 all nighters in
a row I'm just worth
nothing when we think about imposter
syndrome there is another really
interesting tendency that I found which
is called confirmation bias um if any of
you is not familiar with with the
definition of bias bias is a tendency to
think in one way not
necessarily um in a way that's like the
best
option so it's favoring one option over
the others usually with negative
connotations so confirmation bias the
way the way it
works is that if we have this low super
low self-esteem that led to imposter
syndrome or I have really so low
self-esteem
because I just had impostor syndrome if
I hear bad feedback if I hear good and
bad feedback the bad feedback will be
the one that I remember that's
confirmation B because I'm already down
and I'm already anxious and depressed so
even if all of you here will tell me
this was amazing but this one person was
like you know what this was like the
worst talk ever this is the one that I'm
going to remember and positivity and
reassurance is totally unnoticed by by
my brain exactly like you're you're
fantastic you're great you're genius so
handsome but you can be a jerk and the
jerk sentence is the thing that will
stick with
you so this is a bunch of negativity
that can be going on um in your brain
that's trying to sabotage you and in
some cases it might lead to a burnout
which you might be familiar with burnout
is quite new to psychology it was um it
was described in' 70s and it was
attributed mostly to social workers who
were really exhausted because of the all
of the social interaction that they were
getting uh it's a syndrome or of really
severe physical and mental exhaustion
that will draw us away from creating and
from
working and it feeds of um and it feeds
of the lack of faith in ability to
perform we strive for Perfection and we
are perfectly
miserable I was burned out several times
in past 5 years um the worst time that I
I got it was December last year and I
could not force myself to work for 4
weeks and I think it was quite fortunate
that was December and we had our regular
n yet Christmas break
um and that kind of led me to um be able
to chill out a little bit and not guilt
myself into not working for four weeks
um but I've done everything literally
everything to stay away from technology
like I would do anything else watch all
the TV shows on Netflix I would draw I
would hang out with my friends read
fiction practice lettering whatever it
just like cannot involve my lap
top and I really resented technology
although I loved my
job and the reason why um the reason why
I'm giving this talk is because I know
for a fact that so many people probably
so many of you are are or were
struggling with burnout and with
imposter syndrome and all those negative
feelings and um and when I want you to
do is like me try to overcome the
negativity the
sabotage uh sabotaging that our brain is
basically doing on us and our
well-being I feel like the way we do it
is divided in somehow two levels the
personal level and the community or Team
level so starting with
myself and I'm nowhere
near being close to a person who's who
should be giv psychological advice but
these are the things that um I tried on
myself and it certainly improved the way
I work creatively and these were the
things that we also on the team level we
we do regularly and they greatly
improved my creative process so I hope
that you will find something something
for yourself so when you think about me
as a person um or you as a person in a
creative process how do I try to
overcome this negativity well first of
all a try to avoid setting un real
expectations for ourselves and
understanding that failure doesn't mean
that you're not worthy doesn't mean that
you can achieve it just it's just a
necessary mean and sometimes painful
Road
forward I want more people creating for
the joy of creating I'm really bad at
lettering like really bad but I really
love it and the joy of the process of
just sitting with pencil and paper and
throwing scribbling letters is just so
joyful for me and I forget everything
else when I'm doing it and I would like
every single one of you just to find an
activity like that and create for the
joy of creating even then just like
story it in your drawer then show anyone
whatever try to let go of being super
judgmental of
yourself and when you're thinking that
when you're having those negative
feelings I just suck at this job I'm
just like nowhere near this ex person I
just should just quit everything and
technology and CSS and design I'm just
terrible um the feelings those negative
feelings that we are experiencing the
fact is that so many others people are
experiencing the same feelings even
maybe the same moment on the word you're
just not realizing it because you're
just thinking about yourself I'm
experiencing this feelings and I'm alone
with it I'm just like G I just want to
just lay down on the floor and hide that
is not true and the phenomenon that's
behind it is called pluralistic
ignorance where you're thinking that
everyone else is acting in the way
everyone else is acting in a way uh on
the outside basically showing what they
feel so um if I asked right now the
question of how many people had clinical
depression and no one would raise their
hand despite the fact like let's say 20
people headed but it's like kind of a
sensitive topic so no one wanted to
raise their hand I would think okay so
like I might be alone with that because
no one raised their hand and that is not
true and that is PL pluralistic
ignorance of me thinking that everyone
is acting the way they're thinking and
feeling you can't improve the things you
love if you never allow them to imper to
be imperfect we are all in progress we
are not perfect and we won't ever be and
so so is our work so doesn't mean that
like I shouldn't be living because I'm
not a perfect person or I shouldn't be
creating because my creations aren't
perfect no that is not true and they're
perfectly worth our time perfectionism
is anti- creation and iteration is where
creativity grows and Blossoms and it's
really important to remember that it's
okay to be
wrong do you when someone is criticizing
you do you ever stop and for a minute it
when you're getting angry and try to
think why am I getting angry am I
getting angry because this person is
just being mean or am I angry because
this someone is questioning my work or
because I feel like they're attacking me
not my work you're not your idea and if
you're identified too closely with your
idea you will take offense when they are
challenged your work reflects you but
it'll never become
you so switching to the D since we
talked about you switching to the D
scenario of of overcoming negativity we
all work at teams we work at companies
and even if we are fre freelancing we
just we just talking to people and
getting feedback on dribble or wherever
else so um others are just super
omnipresent in in our lives professional
lives and cre creative Liv um so how do
I fight this
negativity ask for feedback
give honest feedback and endorse true
honesty in in giving the feedback strive
for constructive criticism and I don't
like it is not constructive criticism
take an assign responsibility but don't
create fear-driven environments that
will Foster people hiding around corners
and they won't take any risks because
they'll be no I'm afraid because I will
fail trust in people not only to
accomplish what they are assigned to
accomplish but also when they fail that
they will stand up from this
failure there will always be trolls and
people who will bully you always and
there will be people who will criticize
your work especially the more visible
you get the more followers you get the
more recognition you get the worse still
it gets I really like what um Paul
Jarvis said um he calls his audience his
WRA people and is really funny because
my surname means rat in Polish so that's
funny
um he calls rat people his audience
because they understand his work they
appreciate his work and they appreciate
him as a person and that's what I would
like you to do find your audience and
create for them and for
yourself and avoid
conflict and set but set boundaries to
speak up when someone is offensive being
nice does not mean that you'll let
people walk over you and avoiding
conflict does not mean speaking up for
yourself another thing to remember about
conflict especially on the internet on
Twitter wherever else where you're
putting your work at is that if someone
is arguing with you and if you give them
really constructive arguments trying to
win with them they will buck up and they
will totally be more sure about their
argumentation why it's called it's it's
all science it's called the backfire
effect so you might give them the best
best reasoning ever that totally makes
sense and you are right and you should
even win but you want because it will
only
confirm their
beliefs because for our brains myths and
whatever we think it's true is just more
cognitively approachable and attract
active when we are thinking about
communities and teams um it's very hard
to do but it's really important to try
to empower Empower others especially
people who are just beginning to share
their work and Empower them to be better
because that was you once and stop
judging even if their work is really
objectively bad that was also you once
so instead of be judging judging and
negative about their work just try to
help them
instead and if you are the person who is
beginning ask for help it's really not
that hard and if you're thinking oh this
person is too famous I just cannot ask
them they will never reply to me I'm
just like not on the same level no that
is not true you should reach out and ask
for help and many many really visible
people are trying to offer office hours
they will they will even go for coffee
for you with you and offer you really
good
advice so I really I'm know I know it's
a Shameless plug but I'm not feeling
guilty about it um the way I want to
close this talk
[Music]
um about creating really good
environments for for your creativity for
yourself and for your team is um a video
introducing Andia where where I work and
I hope this will
work and yet is um high fives and hugs
and
collaboration and yet is where people
come to do what they love every single
day Ann yet is a group of creative
people who are set out on making not
only the web but the world a better
place and yet is about building trust in
working in their
passionate and yet is a collection of
people a club
really where we get to do uh things that
we enjoy
doing and yet is a place where we
can fail where we can grow where we can
be challenged and we can celebrate each
other's
successes anjet is a place where we get
paid to do the the work that we probably
willingly do for free and yet to me is
the trust and freedom to build something
amazing and yet is a software company
with the goal of making the world a
better place one person at a time the
only way that you can Define and yet is
by what people are doing and what
everybody does is so diverse that it's
hard to come to a um singular conclusion
man is a place to be supported and TR
trusted without
exception what isn't and
yet and yet is a place where bunch of
people are together trying to grow
together as
people can I
go can I
seriously now you can go thank you get
this thing off me anet is a place where
unicorns got to play
[Music]
[Applause]
together I got
[Music]
nothing all right you
ready
okay
okay oh you're
[Music]
ready
so um the takeaway from from this is for
you to find a place like I found I've
never felt more empowered than I feel
working at end yet and I want all of you
to forget for a second the technology
aspect fighting about promises versus
callback stylist over sad or X
technology over y technology and try to
take care of yourself and others around
you and try to be empowering to build a
better we together thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you